so how are you spending your time in
quarantine what how are you passing the
days and the hours a lot of call duty
going on
oh it's turkey season here so I've been
hunting turkeys decent amount so that's
been good watching a lot of TV you know
working out it doesn't look like it but
I am you know just hanging out really
you know trying to keep from going crazy
I guess so are you when you say you're
just watching movies and walks and stuff
what do you want watching right now
you've been Junior well I watched the
entire series of Ozark in about a week
right that was pretty great that was
pretty great entire week like that's
pretty trippy it's pretty moment is
pretty yeah yeah it's Maya my fiancee
had watched the first two seasons and I
hadn't seen any of it so weary watched
it from the start yeah yeah it was great
amazing
now you might speaking of your beautiful
fiance you guys were planning a wedding
tell us where is that at how how are the
two of you handling all of that well
that's the million-dollar question
if I knew where it was that I would tell
you but no I mean things are still think
we're still on track as of right now so
that's all that's all I know
as far as as far as that stuff goes
we're so planning on doing it we're
still we're still planning on doing all
the you know picking out napkins and and
stuff like that so all that stuff is all
systems go as of right now all right so
what are you picking out the napkins
help the the wedding dance song like
where's your expertise like what are you
gonna lend to this cross I need to
understand I'm the I'm like the booze
guy sure probably probably gonna
probably dabble in some playlists you
know I'm sure that will probably happen
I'm just a goodtime engineer on this
thing you know that's the official title
I would give myself I'm not happy
lifting she's doing all the heavy
lifting so would you get involved with
the seating arrangements and who sits
where well you know maybe there is maybe
there isn't formal seating who knows
yeah there's no way to know you know
maybe it's just kind of come as you are
kind of thing there's no way telling was
the date postponed or is the date that
you originally had still kind of it's
it's it's it's it's fine as of right now
I'm getting the feeling that you're only
in on some of the planning well or I'm
just really good at playing my cards
close to my chest could be good at that
I've been watching a lot of those arc as
you know you know I am so incredibly
excited for you to be a part of Canada
together it really does mean a lot to us
just just having you know your stars
shining that on that program for us it's
just so incredibly special why was it
important for you to be a part of it
well I mean we've we've played a lot of
shows in Canada and some of my favorite
fans in the world are up there you know
they've welcomed us with open arms every
time that we've been up there so wanted
to do anything we could especially some
it doesn't require a whole bunch for me
so I just being able to help is really
awesome yeah well we're really really
really grateful I know your fans are
absolutely going to love it you know you
made history this year with
what-you-see-is-what-you-get
you enjoyed the largest streaming week
ever for a country album with 74 million
on-demand streams the first country
album ever to hit number one how did you
celebrate that like
did you go to Turkey shootin did you did
you good time engineer that what did ya
know I just played a show or something
at that time you know things were
surprisingly busy before all this
started so yeah we were probably just
out and about somewhere at that time I
would think we're in the midst of a tour
actually if I remember correctly okay so
you maybe had one or two extra pops that
night yeah one or two extra adult Otis
okay congratulate you on your ACM so you
are in wonderful company there what does
that feel like oh it's great you know I
think just you know being able to I
guess officially be part of that
community is great you know I'm not a
big celebration guy I know that probably
sounds weird but you know I'm constantly
you know you know moving forward I it
doesn't mean I don't sit down and not
celebrate anything either but you know
there's just a lot going on when you
know when we're not in quarantine that
is you know there's a lot going on so
there's not there's not as much time to
sit and smell the roses as I as I would
like so I guess I'm getting getting a
healthy dose of that now you're the guy
who enjoys the journey
you don't just wait bration yeah but
it's all hard work too you know I mean
it's it's things that you know we've
wanted to accomplish you know it's so
it's not just me you know I have a huge
team of you know you know guys in my
band and people on my management team
and people back in Nashville and my
friends my family you know who who've
helped me get to this point so I've
never felt great about you know saying
mimimi
and here's what I did and here's how I
did it there's definitely bigger things
at play for sure yeah well you can
definitely tell you're a guy who
celebrates your successes with your team
in your family together I think that's
you know what draws people to you I
think that that makes you very special
I'm not in that category well thank you
I like to think so yeah
and you're also 30 mm-hmm Oh see how
many wrinkles you have there good not
bad
Oh stress I'm low stress yeah okay so
what's it feel like to be 30 now uh man
it feels like I haven't really been 30
yeah I there was a tornado that came
through Nashville the night of my 30th
birthday so that was interesting and
then I went to Europe and I've been in
quarantine ever since so I haven't
gotten to do much stuff as a 30 year old
except sit around on the couch which I
did a lot as a 20 year old so not really
that different so yeah so 30 for you has
been quite the right though when you
think about so you were out on your
birthday when the tornado hit I was
actually I was actually in this room
here and I had actually had a my fiancee
put together a surprise party and so we
came down here at about I don't know
6:30 or 7:00 there's something like that
this was on March 2nd so this is not
that long ago and then you know we
everybody left and went home and by
about midnight I was in a closet in my
house you know so that was interesting
but yes it's all right you know I you
know I was lucky to be okay where I
where I am here I'm not in you know
downtown Nashville which was hit a lot
harder than then we were here so you
know was definitely fortunate but it
definitely wasn't something I'll never
forget
I'll tell you that much